你跟谁在一起的时候，
你觉得特有安全感，
跟谁在一起的时候，
你可以暴露自己的无知、
幼稚、
虚荣、
恶的那一面，
那个时候可能就是找对了那个人，
因为别人接不接纳你，
别人爱不爱你，
这个事情某种程度上你的潜意识里会知道的。
我不确定这个男朋友要不要分手，
分了很多次，
我说你俩啥情况，
认识多久了，
有什么矛盾？
我们认识一年了，
他比我大一岁，
她98年，
我99年发现我父母和我爸妈不太同意她家庭情况，
我爸的条件希望让我找一个男朋友，
是有全款房，
这样子有稳定工作，
她的工资是我的三倍，
对我家一个月之后他就买了房，
贷款100万，
首付是他们家付的，
当时他提了加我的名字，
因为我们因为房子的事情吵架，
后面手续全部是自己办的，
元旦本来想说的是父母互相父母见面，
但我家里其实不是很认可，
就改成男方去女方家提亲，
进展也不是很顺利，
主要就是我父母，
我和我父母不知道怎么沟通，
他们也不是很认可，
现在将在这儿，
男方觉得他在我这儿没有安全感，
因为我觉得不被需要，
得不到认可的这种，
我这边我觉得没有很信任他，
没有到结婚那一步，
他自己说他爸妈给他的死个命密，
明年必须结婚，
说明年要不我。
姐，
要不然就10月姐，
我觉得我没有认定他这个人，
其实我自己也是内心比较犹豫的，
期间有很多次闹分手，
但是我很奇怪，
每次分手之后和好，
很明显的一个结果，
我俩关系推进，
比如说要见父母，
比如说要同居，
包括这次吵架，
他就提出和好之后我去他新买的房子那儿住，
他自己生活上也有一些改变，
我不是很喜他生活习惯上面，
比如说他坐在上厕所，
你爸妈不同意他，
是因为他没有全款的房子，
所以不同意他，
但是你爸妈并没有觉得他性格有问题，
人品有问题，
长相有问题，
身高有问题，
你爸妈之所以不同意，
唯一的一个点就是因为他没有全款的房子是吗？
他当时给我提个条件，
主要还是和物质有关的，
说就是人品这方面的，
他既然一两层面其实也看不出来，
主要还是看我哦，
那你自己，
你心里面顾虑的点是什么呢？
一个是你爸妈不同意，
另一个你自己在乎的点是什么呢？
犹豫的点是什么呢？
我还没有认准是这个人，
没有认准是这个人总得有原因，
是因为比如说他不是很让着你，
或者是他对你没有那么有耐心，
或者是他对你。
你在物质上也没有太多的愿意付出，
具体是什么点让你觉得犹豫呢？
比如说他很会按摩，
就是手法，
我就觉得他是不是这是猜测哈，
所以我就觉得他有这方面的经验。
另一个就是他的朋友，
他朋友就是说他朋友的未婚妻，
之所以跟他朋友结婚，
是因为这个女生受激宿影响，
所以想结婚，
最后很离谱，
跟他相处这个朋友不是很正常，
那是他朋友的事儿，
跟你男朋友又有什么关系呢？
我觉得物以类聚，
还是有想处，
我感觉啊，
就是说如果一个男人聊说啊，
我女朋友跟我结婚，
主要是受激素的影响，
我感觉这也没有什么太大的问题，
怀孕了是吗？
受激素的影响没有，
她并没有说拿女人的隐私来作为交朋结友的社交货币，
并没有说因为我功夫很厉害，
我老婆得到了满足，
所以她嫁给了我，
没有说这么黄的话，
那我觉得他说一句啊，
我女朋友之所以嫁给我，
她就是受激素的影响，
我没有觉得人家有恶意，
也没有觉得人家有什么不妥呀，
换一个表达方式说啊，
我女朋友之所以嫁我，
就是因为我功夫好，
就她跟我在一起能怎么地的，
如果这么说的话是不对的，
好的，
你看我们聊到爸妈的条件之后，
我是彩礼，
说彩礼和五金的问题，
她同意了，
她有个。
条件是想在房子上加名儿，
但是我现在知道就是加名其实没有什么意义，
我想问如果我后面结婚怎么样更合理一些，
那如果他付房贷，
我日唱开支，
那就是万一，
万一真的离婚的话，
这个是很公平的，
如果说他付房贷了，
你的钱用来日常生活开支了，
那么他付房贷那一部分也是夫妻共同的财产，
分手的时候是可以要求分一半的，
好的，
那其实也不用加名字，
对不加名字也可以的，
但是日唱开支就是不好算，
那人家还贷款那个是有数额的嘛，
对不对？
比如说一个月是还4000块钱，
那么结婚一年的话，
他就还了将近5万块钱，
那你要是跟他分的话，
你能分两万五，
他这个是有数额的嘛，
就看那一半就好了，
是姑娘啊，
我感觉还是谨慎一点，
因为我自己觉得你在这段爱情当中的话，
可能还没有捕捉到关键的点，
到目前为止我所听到的这些你顾虑的点的话，
会让我觉得没有太有逻辑，
比如说他会按摩这个事儿，
有的人他天生他就看一眼，
他就会，
比如说会跳舞这个事儿，
有的小孩他就看一遍电视上怎么跳，
他就会，
有的人他唱歌这个事儿，
他听一遍旋律他都会唱，
不能说因为他会按摩就推导出来说他是不是有过什么服务经验，
或者说这方面啊，
男女关系这方面就复杂就什么的，
这个是逻辑上是不成立的，
是不是对我这边像。
太多了，
我想知道彩礼他有提到过他朋友，
他身边的朋友呢，
带回来或者买车，
换着驾照买车，
我想觉得这样是对的吗？
这个东西没有对和错，
姑娘，
彩礼钱第一我建议你如果将来结婚的话，
是在领结婚证之前，
彩礼钱就要到手，
到你的卡里，
第二呢，
我建议你彩礼钱是单独放在一张你平时不用的卡里，
结了婚了之后不要往里面存钱，
这个彩礼钱能区分的出来，
具体啊，
多少钱，
什么时候打的，
能查出证据来。
第三呢，
这个彩礼钱将来怎么用，
取决于你们两口子感情稳不稳定，
取决于你们两口子经济条件怎么样，
也取决于你们口子以后生孩子养育孩子的支出。
其实这个彩礼钱他没有一条法律规定说必须要用在干什么，
举个例子啊，
没有哪条法律规定说是要给父母啊，
给哪方的父母，
也没有哪条律规定是要给，
要带回来要干嘛的，
这个东西是你自己可以决定的，
将来两口子感情好的话，
这彩礼钱也可以拿出来，
我们一起买车呀，
买房呀，
装修啊都可以，
但前提条件是观察一下，
生活个一年半载，
看看两口子感情稳不稳定，
当然这个彩礼钱也可以拿来给孩子上学呀，
给孩子买什么保险啊什么的也都可以，
这个没有对错，
观察一段时间了之后，
再决定彩礼钱用来干什么，
那您是建议我？
去呢，
还是再观察一下，
因为他说他明年就必须得结婚，
我觉得如果要继续的话，
我觉得你还是听你爸妈的话吧，
因为你确实有点弱，
整个人的状态有点弱，
那你是需要爸爸妈妈的堡护才行。
对好多姐妹都不理解，
你刚刚提到了一个说他坐着上厕所这个事，
你想表达什么意思啊，
那个啥就是有细菌嘛，
所以我希望他坐着上厕所，
他也是这么做的，
我就觉得他也会改变什么的，
你自己没有想好，
自己没有确认的话，
也不要浪费别人的时间精力，
浪费别人的钱，
那我怎么确定他是那个人，
这是一个非常综合的一个判断啊，
你要是遇到一个你特别想嫁的人的话，
你不会来问我的，
但是我还看过很多很骗婚的姿事，
或者把孩子生出来之后才道露我的歉，
所以我比较担心这个，
所以我说你听你爸妈的，
让你爸妈帮你判断判断，
听你爸妈的话，
我父母他其实是想把彩礼留下来的，
但是我觉得你家里还有兄弟姊妹吗？
有他们觉得养育这么多年，
所以是想留下来，
如果你爸妈明确提出这样的要求的话，
那你还是别听你爸妈的了吧，
所以我现在纠结他这个人选品什么的，
就是之前不是很信任他已是这样姑娘啊，
因为我没有办法说。
你的人生去做决策和承担责任，
最终你的人生是要由你自己来承担责任的，
所以你要做这个决定的，
我只能说用一个比较普适的一个标准摆在这里，
你跟谁在一起的时候，
你觉得特有安全感，
跟谁在一起的时候，
你可以暴露自己的无知、
幼稚、
虚荣、
恶的那一面，
那个时候可能就是找对了那个人，
因为别人接不接纳你，
别人爱不爱你，
这个事情某种程度上你的潜意识里会知道的，
如果现在这个男朋友并没有让你真正接纳你自己，
并没有让你在他面前可以很放松的去释放出你那些甚至你自己都不太喜欢的那些阴暗的面的话，
那可能这个人暂时还不是那个对的人。
我说这个，
可能很多姐妹们现在不太能理解龙飞为什么用这个逻辑来判断，
差不多像我们四五十岁的女人的话，
我跟谁在一起的时候，
我一点都不害怕她看到我的阴暗面，
一点都不害怕他来批评我，
评判我，
一点都不害怕他对我会有什么芥蒂，
那那个人就是郑源，
因为我知道他爱我，
我知道他包容我，
我知道我在他面前我对话坏到那种程度了，
他依然包容我，
那个就是正源，
但是我有时候会怀疑我自己是不是防御太强了，
所以不敢暴露，
你不敢暴露就是因为你知道他没有那么爱你，
那再进一步，
其实不是很推。
这个我也不敢说啊，
这个还是你自己做判断好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
有很多姐妹，
尤其是有过几段感情的姐妹，
应该理解。
龙飞姐想表达这个意思，
你跟谁在一起的时候，
你一点不害怕她看你的阴暗面，
一点不害怕看到你不为人知的那一面，
江湖的那一面，
或者说煞气的那一面，
你不害怕他看到，
因为你知道他会包容你，
他会接纳你，
因为你知道他可以通过所有的东西拨开这些迷雾，
你知道他会看到你的底层是什么，
你最坏能坏到什么程度，
你最坏能坏到他的那个程度的话，
他也能接纳你。
记得点赞关注哦。